like the proverbial distinction between
tragedy and comedy the difference
between being an iconoclast and an icon
is time moviemaking has a way of turning
yesterday's rebels into today's
establishment and yet for all of her 60
years of filmmaking and despite her
widespread influence anya sparta has
somehow managed to remain on the cutting
edge paving the way for female
filmmakers around the world in her own
words rebellious Ness is part of being a
woman words to live by when you watch
her work you can see that she's retained
her avant-garde bona fides by following
some simple precepts both obvious and
profound great cinema is real great
cinema is true great cinema is personal
for people who create art whether it's
film or painting or playwriting or
sculpture one problem always lose where
do you start it's a dilemma familiar to
all of us in Anya's films the
jumping-off point is one fundamental to
Modern Life we don't know what we want
but we know it isn't this although Anya
stands with the great European
filmmakers
there's nothing especially foreign about
her movies the issues she explores
burgeois complacency rootless
disassociation and the unexpected nature
and origin of change in our lives are
universal in Anya TSA's films the price
her characters pay for being different
is loneliness
so tonight Anya's we're gathered here to
offer you companionship support and deep
admiration